[Musica]
e da una vita e mezza è come una vita
invece intendo che saranno passati
almeno cinque anni
dove non faccio lo scarta show dei
parchi e dove non flexo
il divano nel lontano lontanissimo 2018
ho chiesto ad alcuni voli inviarmi come
vecchi tempi i pacchi da scartare questa
cosa qua non è poi più successo cioè nel
senso non ho più fatto video a riguardo
e quindi ottenuto i pacchi del 2018 fino
ad oggi cieli ancora qua per i ragazzi
dopo saranno passati credo 67 anni più o
meno facciamo una scarpata dei baci
al rais e sono tutti questi maron questa
pila perché vedete non tenuta per tre
anni procediamo non saranno nè che per
gli heat impolverati però andiamo
vediamo che succede allora particola il
pacco giallo che non si sa di chi è
però credo ci siano le consuete e
lettere dei centristi coli e che l'ha
mandato che non generare senza usare le
forbici proprio come testi
conseguente poco ho lasciato tutto
allora è questo primo pacco abbiamo una
scritta lorenzo grazie mille una molla
io andavo passo perché c'è una sera
quando ero piccolo una molla che grazie
no che schifo
ma cosa ma c'è una striscia di ceretta
spero che non sia usata
un cuore così non si sa di chi si apre
la è un fantastico lg life is good
non c'è un lg dentro però ed
esco e mi unisco di forbice che se non
finirà mai questa come la ragazzi
abbiamo una
bustina chiusa che visse un gioielli
dopo essere che credo che sia più
inquinata non andare a pennello
emissivo rese un vero gioiello con il
simbolo della ricetta e ma bellissimo ma
che storia parlai cadevo quest'altro
ragazzi che bello giga vediamo che cosa
contiene
è una una bacchetta magica che l'amatori
van der
fantastico c'è voluta altro no questo
carta dice una bacchetta magica enorme
conflitto in bosnia
vediamo se mi ha scelto una bacchetta
valido questa te in quest'anno di questa
mi interessa grazie grazie grazie me la
porterò in giro domani e rimorchi a un
sacco ma passiamo pure oltre andiamo a
vedere in questo splendido parco cosa ci
sono c'è chi vuole
[Musica]
che schifo sono
bene se ricordate ma quanti anni ma che
cazzo skip sono ritornati dopo i ragni
pure bello
questo non ho capito c'è una scatola
dentro una scatola
[Musica]
allora c'è un televisore con su scritto
fa vj bellissimo grazie dopodiché
abbiamo un'altra cosa una mia foto con
tanto di piedistallo
grazie all si ammazza la fila anche da
questo per frigida e attenzione molto
fragile è un nuova fix chi
benissimo abbiamo un libro di minecraft
va bene e onigiri non mischiamo non si
cosi un barattolo né di nutella
costituito fa di mandarti e dopo di che
anche un altro mini chi libero stavolta
questo ciò azzeccato tanky questo è
molto molto leggero ma perché c'è un
check c'era questo va dentro c'era
questo e basta non c'è nient'altro io
non so che dire grazie di fazzoletti le
manca il 4 larga non campo altri vediamo
se riusciamo a prendere
sono molto curioso
ecco questo per ischia e
[Musica]
allora abbiamo subito un pick up su
un clic su è una statuina di pikachu che
dice picca sul web tv effettivamente ci
sta e bello però non ho capito il motivo
pro grazie dove abbiamo un poster di di
star link
non so per quanto dice anche stargli
sempre diamente ok fece salita liberismo
spalle poi abbia disney lilo e stitch e
uno buca zoom
va bene grazie avete proprio capito i
miei gusti e non mi sfugge niente
ragazzi all questo è il regio aperto
infatti saranno più rami che regali però
abbiamo lo stesso
volete
c'è un po di silvestro titti o basta
subito metodo subito subito bene e può
così ha omesso questo è un fatto
interessante ma trova bellissimo se qua
a napoli j uno scolapasta l'ho capita
adesso ve li ho adesso abbiamo risolto
l'emblema del parigi con la pasta ecco
perché cessa cosa che fa ricevono
scolapasta e ci stava su internet
non so per quale motivo bene e dopo di
che i ragazzi abbiamo un disegno un
altro disegno un altro di serie di messe
in sala bot carte rick perry
como insomma citate ragazze questo
un gran bel pacco
capitolo e siamo così giunti
altro la sua mamma
mia
dalle cosa
dalle romane de roma
ti vogliamo un sacco bene chiaro e
sandra lei o finisco se foste disco è
una delle mie pagine preferite su di me
tra l'altro perché fanno non so come
riescono a trovare in tutti gli outfit
che ho addosso ea mettere quanto costa
incredibile non so manco io il 4 costa
questa sì ok in realtà non lo so ma sono
curioso di saperlo quindi vediamo siete
così brave nel frattempo desq a torriana
c'è scritto non girare o mettere di lato
io veramente paura che prima di arrivare
qua sia stato fatto perché comunque ha
passato tanti depositi non mi speriamo
che non si è rovinato niente agli atti
ok
abbiamo leggo la sessione degli anelli
non sapendo bene abbiamo fissato regola
e c'era piano e ce l'abbiamo dopodiché
di figo nomine pupazzo di fare niente
freddi ma bellissima bellissimo ma poi
mi conoscete come marco mi madre che non
c'è licenza per esercitare questa è la
licenza dei marchi va bene un astri
lettera
lowery noi
non c'è una scaletta no ragazzi sto male
la regia oscuri cosa hai un account in
you'd like state gameplay
voi ap sono 3 10 just winner note finale
che gli usa leggendario fu il più tool
another live wish nothing like strange
can save our souls creepshow o la fase
d'avvio so much love the phantom
bene o piccole minecraft gay e infine il
diploma di hogwarts dato che non riesce
a prendere la patente babbana abbiamo
pensato che questa fotografia per
spostarti ha la licenza infatti stavo
dicendo tutta la licenza per spostarmi
fighissimo adesso la patente ma non mi
farebbe molto più comodo st miccoli però
va bene signori questa schianta mamma
mia la pantera non c'è una scarpa ci fa
chi è che chiusura che chiuda ragazzi
incredibile spero che questo video vi
sia piaciuto se tifate di sapere magari
non vincerà un altro e magari vide
scatola non due anni dopo ma subito però
abbiamo avuto un po di casi insomma come
al solito se video che ci lasciano
momento è un mi piace anche vari social
come descrizione se non siete presi di
chiedere e noi come sempre ci vediamo al
prossimo video kg l'avvocato bei ragazzi
[Musica]